what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today from new rock stars the exact
moment king killed Iron Man revealed
John how are you how goes holding down
the fort of the real reject it is the
biggest responsibility of my life thank
you for asking how are you sir good I'm
taking it super easy I'm really happy to
hear that from you guys leave a like if
you can that'd be very much appreciated
also that's all let's go to it
[Music]
welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston with King the Conqueror on Deck
as the big bad of Marvel Phase 5 and
phase six a man who in quantumania
footage displays a terrifying amount of
amnesia for the amount of Avengers he
has killed new visual Clues from Loki
revealed in a book
have confirmed that Kang variants are
sadistically collecting trophies from
the adventures that they've conquered We
Begin oh cool what season one ended but
now as we've begun to learn a lot more
about Kang and quantumania footage and
Loki season 2 footage a trailer for
which that I saw at d23 and it will
hopefully drop online before the end of
the year we can actually deduce that
Kang absolutely killed Iron Man Tony
Stark in another timeline and in fact
based off of what we know about Kang
probably just killed him in only one
timeline and I think it might explain
why there was no Iron Man in the
Illuminati in Universe 838 of Multiverse
of Madness oh they're cool you've killed
Tom Cruise lucky the art of the series
includes one page showing concept art if
he main study in the Citadel said
decorator Claudia bonfe gives us a brand
new insight into what exactly we're
looking at here she said that he remains
has a collection of Antiquities the
shells are full of collections that he's
brought back from throughout the
Universe and they are all related to
either a cultural thing or time or just
anything that's interesting or unique
throughout the Universe I didn't want to
put any bright colors in there it was
all black and gold marble so I stuck
with wood tones that would work maybe
something that had a little bit of a
caramel feel to it a warmth and then was
mixed in with Metals okay all right here
we go all right attention really to what
is happening in the scene and not that
dressing but what is your job then if
you're not breaking down every single
thing on those walls there across piece
of gold or bronze or any neighboring
color you should be drawing Clues from
we didn't know every single Easter egg
you're the only one on the internet that
can do it all those gold cracks are just
made of melted Iron Man suits oh nice
try Claudia you did amazing work on this
series I'll give you that but the
psychos here on YouTube are going to
find Easter eggs no matter how hard you
try to hide and promise
there's a crown with two fangs or horns
maybe a headpiece of a Loki and then
over on the right is a chalkboard that
in the series had Newtonian calculus
equations on it but here in this concept
art depicts geometry and trigonometry
reminding us of Spider-Man no way home
when Peter Parker managed to defeat
Doctor Strange In The Mirror Dimension
by trumping Strange's focus on calculus
with a simpler trick of geometry that
calling back Spiderman homecoming when
the first class of Peter Parker's day
was either trigger physics and Peter
knew the answer to the problem because
it involved the kind of trajectory
equations that Peter has to do in his
head every day when he whips around with
his webbing I mentioned all this because
oh wow bad news okay he also
statistically most likely killed a
Spider-Man at some point too now all
these trophies remind us of uncanny
Avengers number eight the King Dynasty
two thousand years in the future where
Kang shows off a trophy room filled with
relics that he snatched him across them
all oh that's really cool multiple cap
Shields multiple Iron Man helmets a
mjolnir magnitude arms Spider-Man mask
Electro Daredevil gear they literally
everything Marvel is in this room but
back in the Citadel over on the left he
remains as a telescope which is
interesting because what exactly is
there to look at from The Citadel other
than the sacred timeline orbiting around
it meaning this Kang variant might
physically look out at moments in
history using this device to inspect
what parts of the timeline must be
adjusted or pruned this telescope now
the latest trailer for Ant-Man the WASP
quantumania show Scott Lang meeting Kang
the Conqueror who offers him a deal to
give him back time if he'll steal back
something that was stolen from him Scott
says he's an Avenger and Kang asks
you're an Avenger have I killed you
before so akang definitely killed an
Iron Man at some point in some timeline
you see the thing is about that line
though that a lot of people are not
reading into at all because yeah sure
there's like plow leaks out of different
and stuff and I don't really know the
details on it the fact that he does not
remember who Ant-Man is at all in that
moment shows that he probably never
killed an Ant-Man before so maybe
Ant-Man is the one who can ultimately
outsmart and defeat gang think about it
if he's the main villain in the first
movie out of phase five which is an
Ant-Man movie how cool would it be if it
came back full circle people the King
Dynasty or Secret Wars were ant-man's
ultimately the one to take him down well
that would be cool because then it would
mean that the Sandman movie beyond the
importance of just having Kang in it and
Kang's plans you know fully revealed and
and microscoped in a pond would mean
that yeah Scott Lang actually has a
fighting chance to be the one to make a
significant difference in this fight
even though you know Kang is definitely
going to appear Beyond quantumania he
remains as an Iron Man helmet but that
doesn't mean he remains was the one to
kill that Iron Man he who remains was
just the king variant who used Elias to
defeat all the other kangs and in that
last multiversal war he remains could
have collected these trophies from other
defeated Kings or even inherited this
whole Citadel from one of the other
kings because remember that broken
statue in the lobby there was a past
struggle in this location now if we
assume several Tony Starks across the
Multiverse had similar life trajectories
at least the way Tony Stark was depicted
in one died in like so many what-if
episodes Nexus moment where it would be
the most important for Kang to stop Tony
dead in his tracks Tony certainly came
close to death in many moments in the
kandar province in Afghanistan flying
through that wormhole in 2012 Adventures
fighting Thanos and infinity war on the
guardianship at the beginning of end
game but I've always believed that the
most important moment in Tony Stark's
life as it pertains to Kang nathana
Richards A Thousand Years Later in the
31st century was this moment this time
in the Mobius strip trip inverted please
[ __ ] yes Tony Stark's discovery of time
travel via Quantum navigation I firmly
believe that this moment and Kang are
connected I love you 3000 Nathaniel
Richard's birth year being 3 000
something and yeah I also believe that
he remains actually
Ultimate Easter egg Nathaniel Richards
needed Tony Stark to make this discovery
in the year 2023 so that a thousand
years later Nathaniel could build on
Stark's research and master the
technology of time travel and Multiverse
hopping if you think about it that way
that actually makes it pretty precarious
for Kang to ever try to kill Iron Man
because he's gonna be neither than that
badly to discover his Missing Link of
time travel for him there would not be
many opportunities after that Discovery
for Kang to kill Tony considering it led
directly to the Time Heist and endgame
in the Battle of Earth in which Tony's
fight with Thanos led to his death
anyway so I think the likeliest universe
in which Kang killed Iron Man was
actually the one Universe we've seen so
far in which Tony was mysteriously
absent Universe 838 of Multiverse
Madness a university we know had some
presence of Tony Stark at some point in
its history with Ultron Sentry Stark
Tech walking around but at the time we
visited it no longer had a Tony sitting
on the Illuminati Deus there was one
open seat but looking back I think it's
likelier that open seat belonged to
either the 838 t'challa or Namor or
maybe balzer the brave I just love where
you're going with this so far because of
the fact that it's connected to Iron Man
oh there's a possibility Iron Man's
influence continues that trajectory of
some type of innovation whether it be a
rise to a hero or create some type of
technological advancement that creates
an Ultron but then him creating
something with time travel or
discovering something that leads to gang
Dynasty like it's it's kind of funny and
ironic at the same time I really do uh
like what you're doing to justify to
help out Marvel because you know when
they're like oh yeah we didn't have an
Iron Man in here and let's just use what
Eric Voss is saying in this video and
that'll explain not just because we
couldn't get a junior to come back or
Tom Cruise let's just use that it's
gonna say yeah it's the perfect excuse
for not having a Tom Cruise cameos I
don't know it just couldn't happen you
know it had to happen this exact right
time and you know on the timeline where
we chose to go with Doctor Strange just
didn't work out he was already dead if
838 Tony Stark was killed by Kang that
would explain why the
why the side effects of dark hole
dreamwalking and not side effects of any
time travel Mechanics for them
Multiverse awards are caused by dark
magic not 31st Century science 838 seems
to be the one Universe without vertical
vertical time travel no Charles Xavier
did reference himself an X-Men Days of
Future Past so who knows it might have
consciousness-based time travel as a
rule to it have I thought more about
this than the filmmakers have at this
point yeah definitely that's what I was
good again
whether by future scientists using
technology or by Wizards and witches
using an evil spell book in dark magic
the Multiverse is destined one way or
another to collapse into chaos it's
almost like neither of these things are
really causing it it's just gonna
collapse on itself anyway and incursions
are the fate of all of us but I want to
ask you do you think we'll ever see a
killing Montage in which Kang Slaughters
Avengers I mean I know marvel did get
cold feet and removed Gore doing the
same thing to the Gods in Thor love and
thunder My Hope Is that they actually
cut that so that it would have more
impact when Kang does it to Avengers in
Kang Dynasty why would that have more
impact both would have impact Gore would
be killing Gods on Avengers so I think
uh you're helping out Marvel well when
we get so that way Marvel can be like
that's why Gore didn't kill all these
Gods because we wanted it to have more
of an impact when uh Kang's killing off
all the Avengers yeah
montages of of characters Mass killing
other characters we gotta tone it down
so the gang still looks formidable but
now I think you're actually pretty right
on about that theory you know even if it
is something that Marvel can just use it
I I like the idea of that's that's the
narrative that they go with ultimately
it's actually it works quite well and I
like I said I like the idea of like
starting with Tony Stark and his
presence of consequences just lingers
throughout the eternity of the MCU it's
really it's neat to me all right guys
what do you think about the city leave
your thoughts down below you can
subscribe to new Rockstar subscribe to
the real rejects leave a like last but
not least
Anissa Oliver we are going through the
first part of November to honor our most
loyal super sexy rejection you must be
one of the sexiest of them all big 5-0
not just physically but longevity wise
too that's right 50 months you have been
with us sexier over time 50 months
that's crazy and not to mention I
remember during the pandemic you were
like contributing like 300 per live
stream it was insane how much your
credit I don't know where all that money
was coming from you must have won
multiple lotteries or something like
that or you just went into the negatives
and now you regret it either way Anisa
we have talked with you so many times
you got to hang out with you in person
and uh you were just an absolute delight
and through all the time of talking with
you before we actually got to hang out
with you in person gotta say you were
even cooler in person than you than the
person would be imagining you to be
talking via the Internet so yeah good
job you're an amazing Spirit an amazing
Soul we love you and forever be in our
heart and someone will just never ever
ever in a million years ever forget ever
thank you
[Music]